[Music]
do you remember what resistance is in an
electric circuit it is something that
controls the flow of current if it's
more then the current reading will be
lower and if it's less then the current
reading will be higher it's inversely
proportional to the current let's talk a
bit more about resistance what are the
factors on which a resistance of a
conductor depends when can we say that
the resistance of a conductor is more or
less than that of another let's do a
small activity to understand this take a
small electric circuit like this one
which has a plucky a power source and an
ammeter in the first case connect a
nichrome wire between these two points
let the length of this nichrome wire be
a lowercase L now plug the key and
measure the reading in the ammeter
now let's try playing with the factors a
bit in the second case we double the
length of the nichrome wire but keep the
thickness same we just double the length
when you measure the reading you will
notice that the current is half of the
current measured originally when the
length was doubled that current halved
in the third case we replaced the wire
with a thicker nichrome wire with length
L understand this case well we're just
increasing the thickness of the wire
without changing the original length L
now if you're increasing the thickness
of the wire it simply means we're
increasing cross-sectional area let's
call it a now when you measure the
current you will notice that it's more
than the original current i1 the results
were getting a pretty interesting let's
try out one last case we use the copper
wire instead of a nichrome wire the
length and cross section area a will be
the same as the original wire but the
material has changed entirely when you
measure the current you will notice that
it's more than I 1
now let's understand the results case by
case we see that as the length of the
wire increases the current reduces by
the same factor it implies that the
current is inversely proportional to the
length of the wire and by Ohm's law we
know that the current is inversely
proportional to the resistance of the
conductor so these two together will
imply that the resistance R is directly
proportional to the length of the wire
more the length of the wire more will be
the resistance note that here we assume
everything else will be constant it will
be the same wire and it will have the
same cross-sectional area and other
factors like temperature will also be
constant so the length of the wire is
one of the factors on which the
resistance of a conductor depends the
resistance of a conductor is directly
proportional to the length of that
conductor the third case tells us that
as the thickness of the wire was
increased the current flowing through it
also increased it tells us that the
current flowing through a conductor is
directly proportional to the
cross-sectional area of that conductor
which means that the resistance will be
inversely proportional to the
cross-sectional area of the conductor
combining these two tells us that the
resistance is directly proportional to
the length of the conductor and
inversely proportional to its
cross-sectional area if we introduce a
constant Rho it can be written like this
this is the constant of proportionality
and is called the electric resistivity
of the material of the conductor in the
fourth case we saw that as the nature of
the material changes the current flowing
through the conductor also changes and
that's because as the nature of the
material changes its electric
resistivity also changes accordingly
conductors for instance have lesser
resistivity as compared to alloys and
alloys have lesser resistivity as
compared to insulators
nichrome is an alloy while copper is a
metal
is a good conductor of electricity and
that's why the current reading increased
when the material change to copper the
SI unit of resistivity is ohm meter how
is it or meter we can look at this
formula and deduce it the unit of
resistance is on the unit of length is
meters and that of area is meter squared
cancelling and transposing the units
gives us the s SI unit of row as ohm
meter we will understand resistivity in
detail in the next video but before we
end this video let's quickly review what
we learned the resistance of a conductor
is directly proportional to its length
and inversely proportional to its
cross-sectional area and it also depends
on the nature of the material if the
material has low resistivity its
resistance will be lower and if it has
more resistivity its resistance will be
higher
[Music]
you